Recall our situation where we want to loop through all of
the elements in all the instances of class B.
And they're pointed to by instances of class A.
What this means is we have to loop through all the A's in order to get to
all of the B's and do whatever we're going to do with them.
This approach if which is involves pointers in
one direction only can be cumbersome and costly.
Instead, you could implement the association between classes foo and bar by
intros, by introducing a new class an association class that has two attributes.
One is a name of or pointer to foo instance and
the other is a pointer to the bar instance.
That is, the instances are essentially a set of pairs.
We have reified or made our association itself into an object.
It's then an easy matter to link through all the possibilities, to loop through
all the possibilities, because they're all instances of this association class.
There is a cost associated with,
with doing this, it, the cost takes the form of an extra step.
If we want to go from a particular foo to a particular bar, instead of having a,
a reference or a pointer directly to it, we have to go to the association
object, look up that particular instance of the foo class,
find the associated instance of the bar class and traverse in an extra step.